what's up everyone masks Nintendo banded
here bringing you a theory video and
this one's about Zelda which just
happens to be my favorite subject by the
way I mean I can make a whole video
dedicated to just why I love The Legend
of Zelda but like you know what maybe I
will anyways so this theory is actually
a fun when I came up with myself and to
be perfectly honest I view it as more of
a fact than a theory now because of all
the proof given to support it but
typically when I tell people about it
they initially dismissed it as incorrect
or just plain false but then I get into
the needy greedy and they start to
realize just how they're so completely
and totally and shamefully wrong if I
were to tell you that there was only one
Ganon across the whole Zelda timeline
would you believe me if you said yes
great give this video like smash that
subscribe button go on your merry way
knowing that you're a smart educated
overall fantastic person but if you said
no then please continue watching as I
dazzle you with all my facts
first off let's take a look at the
timeline for those of you not completely
familiar with the official Nintendo
approved timeline I'll be making a video
that's shortly in my attempts to
simplify it for y'all smartphone but
anyways this is the quick rundown of it
as you can see it is split into three
count of three timelines after this game
right here takes place The Legend of
Zelda Ocarina of Time now where did we
first see Ganon aka Ganondorf from the
Zelda timeline chronologically speaking
right here in this massively important
Zelda game he is first introduced to us
when we play as a young dashing child
link who's fooling around with a pretty
girl Zelda in her own backyard
anyways Ganondorf is introduced as a man
with evil eyes aka the big bad guy who
you're probs gonna have to have some
epic climactic battle with at the end of
the game or somehow
fast forward until the game's end and
here's where it all starts to make sense
as adult Lane you beat the crap out of
mr. pig demon Lord and sent him
screaming literally screaming curses at
you and the sages into a great magic
seal no not that kind of sealed like a
seal that blocks something away gosh
that's no pity no and then Zelda's all
like you shall not pass and sends link
back into his original timeline and at
the end end of the game the final image
that is shown is of link standing in the
same backyard slash courtyard with Zelda
his boo obviously first meeting so
before they have even discussed the man
with the evil eyes however she's
obviously peeking in the window looking
at him there
okay so already we have two endings to
Ganondorf in this game first off as
adult link you straight-up mauled a
player and sent him into the seal of the
sages let us now go to the next game in
the adult timeline aka the timeline that
playing as adult link in Ocarina of Time
spawn Wind Waker according to the very
first thing you see in this game
legend has it of the people in Wind
Waker that the boy in green appeared out
of nowhere when Gannon was thrashing
everything up and defeated him and
concealed him away and then vanished
back without a trace this still wait for
his return to this day before of course
you play has lake in Wind Waker see the
connection link from Ocarina of Time
pops seven years into the future in his
adult form which as a side note was as a
17 year old notably which some people
would possibly have still referred to as
a boy and then popped back into his
original timeline after he sealed Ganon
away never to return again to that time
this is obviously referencing the hero
of time from ocarina of time so that
would mean that also this is the same
guy who broke out of his seal now
wanting to claim Hyrule's wind as his
own and at the end of the game link
straight-up stabbed him in the friggin
head and seals the end in a way again
with a different sort of power at the
bottom of the great sea where he sleeps
forever along with the Master Sword the
other games in this timeline do not have
Ganon in them which means that he has
now effectively been killed up in the
adult timeline next up we have the kid
timeline aka the original hero of times
timeline the next game in this timeline
is Majora's Mask which in and of itself
spawns so many different theories and
questions just within the game alone
many of which I will touch on later but
ok this is a side note but I just got to
say it link is not dead in this game and
I will make a video proving why later
anywho we're skipping this game since
Ganon is not present in it and we're
going straight on to the next one
Twilight Princess now this game sort of
hick and it's presents in it until the
mid to end of the actual game when you
confront and defeat Zant the usurper
King it is then revealed that Ganon was
the one behind the scenes all along that
was giving them to his power and stuff
so it's time to switch main villains
this Ganon's backstory is rather
different than that of Wind Waker
scandic however due to Ocarina of times
Kid and now this ending is understood
but what happens after the credits in
ocarina of time is linked informs Elda
and the king of Ganondorf his true
intentions and how evil his eyes really
are and they end up attempting to
execute him immediately this is shown in
Twilight Princess when the sages stabbed
Ganondorf in the TomTom and ultimately
it doesn't kill him he just gets mad
breaks a handcuff and kills one of them
but the other sages as a last minute
quick mix sent him you guessed it
screaming into the Twilight Realm to be
sealed away anyway is fast forward to
the end and links straight up stabs him
through the stomach the same spot where
they stabbed him earlier the so ghoul
and Ganondorf dies ultimately
in a very cinematic way the other game
following his Four Swords Adventures and
yeah Ganondorf does not return so now we
haven't killed up in two times on to the
third and notably most complicated work
thirdly we have the falling timeline
which occurs if the hero is defeated
again how this happens I'll cover more
of in another video but for now we'll
just go ahead and go with it
so pretty much what happens in this
timeline is obviously Ganon isn't
defeated at the end of Ocarina of Time
Lincoln so therefore Ganon plunges the
land into eternal bad stuff forever and
ever and yeah it is pretty much not good
overall that is until the next link
emerged the link in a Link to the Past
now between this game here and this game
here a battle took place this is
important because as a result of this
battle between the good awesome people
of Hyrule and Ganon's evil nasty army
Ganon was ultimately sealed away of
course in the Sacred Realm this time we
could also refer to this realm as the
golden land but also known as the actual
resting place of the Triforce Ganon then
simply waltzed up to the legendary drive
horse and wished for all two powers but
it could not grant him entrance back
into his light world where he was from
so instead he turned the entire Sacred
Realm into his own dark room hoping to
eventually build up enough power to get
back into the light world and get right
back to straight up wreckin now in the
game a Link to the Past link travels
into the dark world and actually kills
Ganon bear in his own realm like a boss
after this game is over again its
followers in the years to come try to
resurrect him here and there but
ultimately link just shuts it down every
time
thus Ganon really is no more unless of
course someone tries to resurrect him
and Link doesn't stop them so what have
we learned boys and girls well as you've
just seen there really was only one
Ganon split into three along with the
end of ocarina
we even see the corresponding character
traits in windwaker he's more refined
and you actually almost feel bad for
fighting him sometimes as he is quite
the scholar with his speeches about
prosperity for his people and wins and
whatnot this is the Ganondorf who was
defeated at the end of the Ocarina of
Time adult timeline after already ruling
the land for seven years and does has
already been beaten and had a lot of
time out time in his own personal seal
to think about what he's done and what
he should now do the Ganondorf in
Twilight Princess is much more violent
and just straight of evil this is the
one that never got to rule and was
immediately sealed away with fresh sage
blood on his hands and was also stabbed
in the gut her DP owed about that I mean
I would be and the one in the Link to
the Past is the Ganon that never
experienced failure and ruled for a very
long time until being sealed away so
he's more cowardly and runs away from
link all the time throughout the game
and is afraid of having it all taken
away again Ganon really was this one guy
with a lot of evil power from his great
great great great great great times a
million granddaddy demise who promised
the hero that an incarnation of his
hatred would always follow the heroes
bloodline
and chillin anyway there you have it if
you guys like this video please do leave
me a like I would appreciate that mucho
and I don't know maybe buy you a coke or
something I don't know maybe her hey
even better hit the subscribe button
that would really make my day I have no
doubt that I would possibly buy you a
coke if you did anyways guys it's been
real check out some of my other videos
for more Zelda theory and more boots